Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Assessing how similar two images are has been
a long standing problem in computer graphics.
For instance, if we write a new light simulation
program, we have to compare our results against
the output of other algorithms and a noise-free
reference image.
However, this often means that we have many
noisy images where the structure of the noise
is different.
This leads to endless arguments on which algorithm
is favorable to the others, since who really
gets to decide what kind of noise is favorable
and what is not?
These are important and long-standing questions
that we need to find answers to.
In an other application, we took a photorealistic
material model and wanted to visualize other
materials that look similar to it.
However, in order to do this, we need to explain
to the computer what it means that two images
are similar.
This is what we call a similarity metric.
Have a look at this reference image, and these
two variants of it.
Which one is more similar to it, the blurred
or the warped version?
Well, according to most humans, warping is
considered a less intrusive operation.
However, some of the most ubiquitous similarity
metrics, like computing a simple per-pixel
difference thinks otherwise.
Not good.
What about this comparison?
Which image is closer to the reference?
The noisy or the blurry one?
Most humans say that the noisy image is more
similar, perhaps because with enough patience,
one could remove all the noise pixel by pixel
and get back the reference image, but in the
blurry image, lots of features are permanently
lost.
Again, the classical error metrics think otherwise.
Not good.
And now comes the twist, if we build a database
from many of these human decisions, feed it
into a deep neural network, we'll find that
this network will be able to learn and predict
how humans see differences in images.
This is exactly what we are looking for!
You can see the agreement between this new
similarity metric and these example differences.
However, this shows the agreement on only
three images.
That could easily happen by chance.
So, this chart shows how different techniques
correlate with how humans see differences
in images.
The higher the number, the higher the chance
that it thinks similarly to humans.
The ones labeled with LPIPS denote the new
proposed technique used on several different
classical neural network architectures.
This is really great news for all kinds of
research works that include working with images.
I can't wait to start experimenting with it!
The paper also contains a more elaborate discussion
on failure cases as well, so make sure to
have a look.
Also, if you would like to help us do more
to spread the word about these incredible
works and pick up cool perks, please consider
supporting us on Patreon.
Each dollar you contribute is worth more than
a thousand views, which is a ton of help for
the channel.
We also accept cryptocurrencies, such as Bitcoin,
Ethereum and Litecoin.
Details are available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!